مساء الخير واهلا وسهلا فيكم بحلقه جديده
من برنامجكم بعد الصافره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
القصه وما فيها انه باريس سان جيرمان خسر
من لوريان ثلاثه واحد بالدوري الفرنسي يوم
الاحد ميسي بعد بيومين قالوا لباريس سان
جيرمان السلام عليكم ما راح احضر تدريبات
انا مسافر على السعوديه عندي عقد باوزاره
السياحه السعوديه ورايح اعمل دعايه
للمواقع السياحيه في المملكه وصل مسجد الى
السعوديه وزير السياحه السعودي نشر الصور
رحب بمسي الامور تمام الجميع سعيد ومبسوط
وما عنا اي مشكله ولكن فجاه ومن حيث لا
ندري بيطلع خبر على صحيفه التكييف
الفرنسيه
وعند الصحفي المختص بشؤون الانتقالات وسوق
الانتقالات
اللي طلعوا قال باريس سان جيرمان قرر
معاقبه ليونيل ميسي بسبب سفره الى
السعوديه وهذه العقوبه بتشمل منعه من
التدريبات لمده اسبوعين وبالتالي لن يشارك
مع الفريق بالمبارتين القادمتين بالدور
الفرنسي هون تفجرت
الاخبار حول العالم وبلشت الناس كلها
تتداوله وتحكي فيها وتحلل تداعيات
والتبعات شو اللي صار وكيف صار هيك نحن
اليوم جايين نجاوب على سؤالين اول شيء
ميسي ليش تصرف بهذه الطريقه رغم انه عبر
مسيرته الاحترافيه كلها كان يعرف بانضباطه
وانه دائما ملتزم مع الفريق وملتزم
بالتدريبات وما عنده مثلا حركات نيمار
وغيره من اللاعبين والسؤال الثاني كيف راح
تاثر هاي الخطوه على مستقبل ميسي الموسم
المقبل
قبل مبارح لما كنا نحكي عن مستقبل مسي
الموصل المقبل كنا نحكي على ثلاث خيارات
اول خيار هو البقاء مع باريس سان جيرمان
ثاني خيار هو الانتقال الى برشلونه وثالث
خيار هو الانتقال الى الهلال السعودي او
انتر ميامي الامريكي ولكن بعد اللي صار
امبارح صرنا امام خارب اما برشلونه او
الهلال لانه كثير من الصحف الفرنسيه
والاسبانيه والمحللين والصحفيين شافوا انه
هاي العقوبه هي بمثابه بين قوسين وورقه
طلاق ميسي وباريس سان جيرمان ونهايه
العلاقه بين الطرفين هذا بيعني انه ميسي
صار امام الانتقال امام خيرين اما
الانتقال للهلال وانتر ميامي او الانتقال
الى صفوف برشلونه بموضوع برشلونه او بما
يخص انتقال ميسي لبرشلونه الموضوع يبدو
صعب وشبه مستحيل لانه اوراق برشلونه
الماليه راح تمنعه من التعاقد مع ليونيل
ميسي
على ما يبدو وحسب برنامج
المعروف باسبانيا يبدو انه انتقال ميسي
لبرشلونه صار عمليه شبه مستحيله لذلك بظل
عنا خيار الانتقال امال الهلال او انتر
ميامي طيب ميسي لما غادر
باريس لوين اتجه اتجه على الرياض لما يتجه
على الرياض معناتها انه هو رايح كسفير
للسياحه السعوديه لهون الامور تمام وما في
اي شيء ممكن يثير التكهنات حول المستقبل
ليونيل ميسي ولكن لما نعرف انه فابريزو
رومانو حكى قبل فتره انه الهلال قدم عرض
لميسي بقيمه 400 مليون يورو سنويا وهو ما
يعادل تقريبا عشره اضعاف راتبه مع باريس
سان جيرمان ولما نسمع انه باريس سان
جيرمان اصلا كان ناوي يطلب من ميسي انه
يخفض راتبه الموسم المقبل لانه العقد بين
الطرفين هو لمده موسمين بدا بموسم
2021-2022 وموسم 2022-2023 مع خيار
التمديد لمده موسم بنفس الراتب بحال وجود
حاله تراضي بين الطرفين ولكن على ما يبدو
انه حاله التراضي هاي مش موجوده لنستعرض
مسيره ميسي مع باريس سان جيرمان ميسي
بالموسم الاول مع بي اس جي كان عم يلعب
بدون شغف لانه كنا بنعرف انه ميسي كان
منتقل لباريس سان جيرمان اصلا مضطر ان
برشلونه فشل بتسجيله لذلك شفناه بالموسم
الاول مش مرتاح مش عم يلعب مبسوط ما في
شغف مش بس اللي بنعرفه مع بدايه الموسم
الحالي بس اختلف شفنا اداء جيد شفنا اهداف
شفت صناعه اهداف شفنا نفحات من ميسي
برشلونه ولكن التحليل المنطقي كان بوقته
بشكل يعني بدنيا وفنيا لكاس العالم من شان
يلعب كاس العالم ويكون جاهز وبالتالي بعد
نهايه كاس العالم اختلف اداء ميسي تماما
عاد ميسي اللي فاقد الشغف عاد ميسي اللي
مش عم يقدم اداء جيد بعد باريس سان جيرمان
وهذا الامر ادى لان شفنا صافرات استهجان
عليه من قبل جماهير الفريق الفارسي ربما
لاول مره في تاريخ ميسي من لما بلش كره
قدم هاي المعطيات كلياتها بتقولنا
الاستنتاج
انه ميسي ما عاد مؤمن بمشروع باريس سان
جيرمان لانه لما طلع رئيس النادي ناصر
الخليفي بالصيف
عقد كيليان مبابي وتحدث عن مشروع رياضي
جديد في باريس سان جيرمان بقياده اوكامبوس
وقالتيه المدرب الموجود حاليا خلال الموسم
الحالي شفنا انه باريس سان جيرمان على
الاقل اوروبيه فشل وعلى المستوى المحلي
باريس سان جيرمان على بعد خمس نقاط فقط من
خساره لقب الدوري لانه مارسيليا وراه بخمس
نقاط مع تبقي خمس جولات على الدوري
الفرنسي مجرد وجودك بهذه الحاله بالدوري
الفرنسي كباريس سان جيرمان هذا بحد ذاته
مشكله كبيره بالنسبه للفريق الفارسي
وبالتالي ميسي ما عاد مقتنع بمشروع باريس
سان جيرمان وبالتالي لما ميسي بيغادر
الفريق مثل باريس وبيحمل حاله بعد خساره
امام لوريان سببت غضب كبير لجمهور
الباريسه ويحمل حاله ويروح على السعوديه
فهو هون بشكل او باخر حسب وجهه نظري عم
يبعث رساله انه هو يفضل مشروع على مشروع
عم بيقول حرفيا لاداره باريس سان جيرمان
انا ما عم باقتنع بالمشروع وانا عندي
التزامات اخرى ربما تكون اهم بالمرحله هاي
من وجودي مع الفريق وهو الامر الذي اغضب
اداره باريس سان جيرمان ومنطقيا ومهنيا
طبعا معها حق تغضب لانه هذا التصرف مش
احترافي نهائيا من جانب ليونيل ميسي
الذهاب الى السعوديه ايضا بخليك تفكر
بامور اخرى يعني مثلا ميسي جايب معه
عائلته على السعوديه طيب هو كسفير مش مضطر
انه يجيب عيلته وهون في تفسيرات تفسير
الاول انه هو جاي ليعرف عيلته على
السعوديه وعلى اساس انه المكان اللي ممكن
انه يكونوا موجودين فيه الموسم المقبل
بحال انتقاله للهلال الثاني انه هو والله
يعني جاب عيلته هيك من باب الترويج
للاماكن السياحيه بالسعوديه المناسبه
والملائمه للعائلات هذا التصرف طبعا مثل
ما حكينا هو تقريبا بدايه نهايه ميسي مع
بي اس جي وهو ايضا مشكله جديده لاحد قطبي
كره القدم باخر عقدين من الزمن وهو ليونيل
ميسي بعد ازمه رونالدو مع مانشستر يونايتد
واللي انتهت بمقابله بيرس مورجان وخروج
رونالدو من مانشستر يونايتد وانتقاله
للنصر السعودي
فمعنى هذا الكلام انه برايي الشخصي فرص
انتقال ميسي الى الهلال الان هي الاعلى
اول نظرا لانه الراتب مغري جدا بالنسبه
لميسي 400 مليون بالسنه اذا صحت الارقام
اللي عم يتحدثوا عنها بوسائل الاعلام 400
مليون يعني رقم خرافي يعني راح يكون اكثر
رياضي بالعالم
على صعيد الاجور وهذا امر مناسب بالنسبه
لميسي لانه ميسي كرويا حقق كل شيء جاب
دوري الابطال جاب الكاس جاب الدوري جاب كل
شيء ما عاد عنده اي طموح او هدف باوروبا
حققوا وبالتالي قال الاوان لانه يفكر بانه
يعمل مشروع مستقبلي يفيده حتى بعد نهايه
مشواره الكروي وبراي المشروع الامثل بهذه
الحاله هو مشروع السعوديه لانه ميسي راح
يكون سفير للسعوديه وسفير لكاس العالم
2030 الى السعوديه عم تسعى انه هي تستضيف
النقطه الاخرى انه طالما انه الموازنه بين
العقل والقلب القلب غير قادر على انه
ياخذك لعنده عم نحكي عن برشلونه
فبضل عندك الخيار العقل هو الخيار الامثل
والاتجاه نحو السعوديه لبدايه مشروع جديد
بكل الاحوال هاي مجرد تكهنات وهاي مجرد
تحليلات للمشهد ولكن على ارض الواقع لحد
الان ما في شيء رسمي غير انه ميسي هو سفير
للسياحه السعوديه هو رايح على السعوديه
لاعمل ترويج للاماكن السياحيه الموجوده
بالمملكه برفقه عائلته هذا كان كل شيء
بحلقه بعد الصافره حتى نلتقي الاسبوع
المقبل كونوا بالف خير